咱这节课讲电视剧啊。
电视剧呢好多同学问过我说啥时候讲讲呀，该讲电视剧了吧。
这个为啥这么着急呢？
是因为很多同学在外面找不到电视剧的教材。
确实没有。
确实没有像样的没有。
为啥这个电视剧的教材那么少呢？没有没有人教呢？
是因为电视剧。
总共就出来这么几十年。
他的历史很短。
然后形态。
一直不太稳定，它一直在发展变化。
所以你让那些老师怎么去。
这个出一套教材，怎么给你总结出一套方法呢？
所以确实不好弄。
但是听咱这个课的同学，你们有福了，我会讲。今天我给大家讲一讲啊。
今天天气很冷，所以又戴了个帽子啊。本来在室内啊其实是不应该戴帽子的，现在不太礼貌。
但是听过我课的同学都知道我光头这个温度低的时候，这个确实脑袋发凉，今天戴个帽子讲啊。
好，今天说电视剧。
这个电视剧啊。
你说他没有教材，那那市面上这些电视剧他们都咋写的？
就这个电影学院那些毕业的那些学生，他们怎么去从事电视剧这个行业呢？
其实电视剧的写法啊，现在大家一般都是从就是大家先去学电影，学戏剧那套东西学会了以后。
从那演变出。
电视剧的写法。
根据电影的模式，再根据电视剧的市场需要变化演化出来的写法，基本上都是土土办法自己琢磨的。
所以这也是为什么我把这个课放在这时候讲，就是你电影的故事套路，大家得先懂了，先了解了，有基础了才能聊电视剧。否则我跟你说这个这个调用那些故事写法的时候，你都听不明白，那肯定是不行的。
所以你得先会电影故事的套路。当然这不是说电视剧的写法比电影高级，比电影难，没有这个意思，它是两种不同的形态。
都是讲故事，但是形态不一样。因为我第一节课的时候说过，因为他他的播放方式不一样，观看习惯不一样，那他肯定有区别嘛。
说到这个电电影和电视剧的区别啊。
很多同学问过我一个问题。
就关于这个影视圈的这个骑视链的问题。
说拍电影的是不是瞧不起拍电视剧的对吧？你看那些电影演员有些完全不演电视剧啊。
有没有这种歧视？
平良跟你说。
有。
肯定有。
但是有不代表他对。
明白这个意思吗？
每一个行业都有提示链。
每一个环境里面都有起始链，甚至连地狱都你你籍管是哪都有起始链。
对吧大城市的小城市的、城镇的、乡村的。
是吧南方的东北的。
海边的内陆的没有歧视吗？
有。
但是你说他对吗？他当然不对呀。
所以说。
关于电影骑士电视剧这个事情啊。
也是不对的。
最起码现在是不对的。因为以前来说，电视剧可能。
制作确实比较水。
然后造成拍电影的人就会觉得那我们是搞艺术，你们是哎呀。
这个这个搞市场了，但是现在市场经济了呀，搞市场没有什么不好，对不对？
更何况其实完整提实链是这样的啊。
电影骑视电视剧电视剧其视网剧网剧可能还在歧视个网大。
网大呢还歧视什么呃短视频和直播带货。
这是完整的起始点。
但问题你觉得这个骑士链它它对吗？它可靠吗？
一个新巴出来全给你干服了，人家就是直播带货了，人家捐了1550。
你你你这个食物链顶端的电影你捐多少？
是不是？
所以说谁是弟弟不好说。
时代不一样了，没必要搞骑视，特别是咱们创作者，那些骑士他们去聊就算了。咱们是编剧，咱们是创作者。
咱们拿到一个故事，或者咱们有了一个灵感，写成一个故事，要表达出来要呈现给观众。
他适合搞成电影就搞电影，他适合搞电视剧就搞电视剧。
他有可能只适合搞成小品，那就搞小品。
有可能他只是一个情怀，一种情感那。
更适合搞成一个歌词，那你就写什么歌嘛？
就是这样子没有什么歧视。
不要去聊这个问题。
没有意义，因为你在写故事的时候，你就全力以赴就可以了。
你不可能牛逼到说，哎，我今天接了一个电视剧的一个剧本，我写的时候我的功力我收一收吧，我只用五成功力就可以了。你吹牛逼呢在哪？
你都得全力以赴去写，好好写。
那咱们就开始说这个电视剧。
电视剧。
首先我们得了解电视剧是个什么玩意儿。
这个很重要。
它是个什么玩意儿？
决定了他的。
形态。
决定了它的价值，决定了它的特点。
就说电视剧啊它是个什么玩意儿？我们先说电视剧从哪儿来的啊。
电视剧。
就是这几十年的。
发展起来的。
他是跟着谁出来的呢？
跟着电视机出来的。
有了电视剧以后，才有了电视剧。
而且这个电视剧最早是干啥用的呢？
他是勾引你看广告的。
明白这个意思吗？
就是有了电视机以后。
电视机要放广告给你看。
但是不能光让你看广告啊。
光你看广告，你不看呀，你不上这个当。
然后他们就拍一些电视剧在那里放。
让你看这个电视剧。
麻痹。
给你吃个药引子，然后趁你不注意。哎广告来了，强制你看广告。
这就是电视剧。
最早产生的它的出身，它的作用。所以电视剧我们给他的定义，它可以说就是。
广告的。
马仔。
电视剧是电视广告的马仔。
你可以这么去理解。
那既然他是电视广告的马仔。
那就决定了第一。
他得。
大量的填充时间。
对吧。
第二呢，他不能让你太累。
对不对？
他不能太消耗你的精力啊。
他要让你很舒适看的。所以你看电视剧的剧情强度一般还比电影弱。
然后呢，他要陪伴你，让你不厌烦，所以他他得是人物驱动，人物才能陪伴你吗。我说过电视剧给你一种谈恋爱的体验。
对不对？
人物呀陪伴你呀，这是一种恋爱呀。所以你看电视剧的观众也是女性观众，他为啥要女性观众呢？因为看广告冲动消费的是女性观众，女性观众看电视剧咔嚓来个广告。然后呢，在广告一看，哎，这个东西这个洗面奶好像我可以买，买了以后，这个钱被洗面奶洗洗面奶的。
商家赚走了，他赚到这个钱，付一部分给电视台，说这是我的广告费。电视台再拿出这个钱一部分去给电视剧说做的好做的好。
对吧小弟，你做的好。
是这么一个支付转移支付的一个路径。
所以。
导致了。
电视剧基本描的是女性观众，因为女性观众更爱冲动消费呀，对吧？
所以造就了电视剧。
早期的特点是连续的。
然后呢呃大量填充时间，但是又不消耗精力，以人物为驱动。
很nice很温柔。
陪伴你。
早年的时候啊。
你什么时候见过说有一个电视剧是恐怖电视剧，不可能的对吧？他不给你来这一套，他就是陪着你。所以最早的电视剧基本都是爆米花剧。
喜剧啊、爱情剧啊。
他陪着你，但又不消耗你精力。
这就是。
电视剧它的出身。所以你说电视剧我给他的定义啊。
我说他就是电视广告的马仔。
很多同学。
就说了说老师，你能不能给点正经定义呀？书上那种电视剧是一种什么什么光影和什么什么的呃艺术形式，艺术形态哎呀。
咱也不考试，你去背那些有什么用呢？
在这里我跟大家说一下啊。
如果你。
再去上别的编剧课。
听到一个老师天天给你甩术语。
我建议你掉头就走。
有一种老师特别爱甩术语。
动不动就给你，这是罗伯特买基啊，这是呃这个这个希德菲尔德啊，这是那个那个斯坦尼斯拉夫斯基。
就给你整这是什么什么理论。
把这些东西搞得过于玄妙。我跟你说，这种老师。
这么讲的话。
有很大的怪率，就是他可能也是不会呀。
他不会写，你知道吗？
这就好比什么啊，好比你去学个厨师。
你其实是想炒菜，回家开个饭店，有个手艺。
可以谋生，对吧？
这老师天天在跟你跟你。
跟你说一些啊，这个青椒的切法有三种，一种是川菜名家，叫刘二贵刀法。刘二桂刀法是三横一竖咔但是呢到70年代后期的时候，因由于青雕技术的发展，青椒长得越来越大，它改成了四横两竖切法。
背这些有什么用啊？
这些也就是他吃饭的时候，你吹吹牛逼可以可以说，对吧？上来一道菜，哎，这个青椒是是这种切法，你知道吗？这是川菜名家刘二贵切法的一种变种。
你就给我吹一个牛逼的。
咱们这堂课啊，我就教你切啊，教你做，咱们得会做。
因你背这些啊没有用。
吹这个牛鼻胡这个人干什么呢？天天啊呀一一直就哇，这是这是什么？这是这叫什么就拿术语在那套，没有必要。
还是得学会正儿八经的干活。所以我说你如果去再去上别的编剧课，听到老师拼命的甩术语。
我跟你说，十有八九，他可能就不会教你写了。
他也还不会。
还有一种老师啊。
还有一种老师就骗人的老师有两种，有两个特点，一个是拼命的甩术语。二是大量的讲案例。
就今天我们带大家来看一下经典影片，这个杀手不太冷。我跟你讲何特别爱讲这个杀手不太冷。一听有人讲这个杀手不太冷，我劝你掉头就走。
当然是牛逼片子，当然是好片子，满分剧本写的非常棒。但问题。
他花一天的时间跟你讲这个呃电影。
每一场戏都跟你讲，这场戏的精妙之处在哪里，作用在哪里？你听着也很过瘾，觉得啊真棒呀，这个电影真棒呀，有什么用呢？
你会写吗？
说人家棒。
有什么用啊？你自己在家看也能看出这个电影很棒。
对吧给你讲一件阳光小美女是如何的哎呀，规整如何的漂亮，对吧？给你讲一下那个斯皮尔伯格的回到未来这个剧本如何的完美。
这种课呀也去少听。
而且这种课一般。
这种线下课好几万一组。
他花大量的时间在那里给你讲案例。
听我我的课的同学。
你们前面的课如果好好听了，我告诉你，你现在自己看这些片子，你都能给他分解了，你都能感受到他每一场戏的作用。你只要好好听我的课了，所以不需要我带着你去。
分析这种案例，因为我有同学给我留言，主动求我带他们分析案例，你知道吗？
那是浪费你的时间，也是浪费我的时间，咱又不不不拿时间充数去卖钱，何必呢？没有必要，好吧，没有必要你自己看就行了。我教你什么呢？我这里如果需要举例子的时候，我教你写一个，这才是最好的，你能了解到我们怎么写出来这场戏。比如说我们这在这里。
需要一个。
呃，男方跟女方呃产生。
男女主角产呃产生分歧。然后呢，但是男主角不知情，女主角知情。比如说咱们现在需要这么一场戏，那咱们就现场一起写，这才解决问题。从0到1这才解决问题。所以咱们课上有大量的我带着你们写写，带着你们创作的。
时候。
而不是去分析一些。
阿牛的东西。
人家这场戏真牛啊，来同学们鼓掌哦，牛牛牛啊，这个服了我服了。
有什么用啊，我也服。
服了有什么用啊？
是吧这个杀手不太冷，那当然还牛逼啊，那个片子。
豆瓣怎么也得个9.49.5左右的那种，那非常完美的剧本，对吧？
没什么好分析的，你听了我的课之后，你自己去看，你自己一场一场去看，你自己都可以分析。
好吧，所以以后再不要跟我说这个了，以后你们看到这种课也可以别报名了，那3万块钱省下来干点什么不好，买点排骨吃的不香吗？
对不对？那种课真的三四万一套啊。
他就带着你讲案例。
咱们这堂课不干这种事儿，咱们是实战课，我带着你们写。
需要举例子的时候，我带着你们直接写，这才是能学点东西，好不好？所以以后咱别聊这个了啊，也别聊什么这个电视剧到底是什么定义，你不用去管，我就告诉你，电视剧就是电视广告的弟弟，电视广告的马仔。
他就是这么来的，他就服务电视广告呀。
给电视广告填空留缝。
就是这个作用，所以才造就了他早期的形态。
比较女性像啊比较人物驱动，比较不耗费精力，比较看着比较舒服。这就是电视剧的早期心态。而且为了大量的填补你的时间，它需要批量生产，批量生产，它就搞成了叫连续剧。你看电视剧也叫连续剧嘛，啥叫连续剧。
他剧情连续啊他剧情连续着。
所以他就可以啊。
长时间的叙事来完成他的使命。
给广告当小弟的这个使命。
有有剧情连续的对吧？那还有那种单元剧一集，比如说一集破一个案。
那种侦探片那种也有那种就是呃他人物连续。
他一直是这些人儿，对吧？还有情景剧，他场景连续，他就这一个场景，或者就这几个场景。
他反正他连续批量生产。
就就就是因为这个原因造就了电视剧是这个形态。我们也要了解这个，便于我们创作。
当下你手里这个电视剧需要完成什么任务？
去创作，按照那个形态去创作。
那直说到这里。
我们可以回顾一下，我们说电视剧它形态一直在变化。
我们可以回顾一下电视剧这些年啊，特别是中国这个电视剧啊。
他是怎么发展的？因为我本人出生在80年代的早期，80年代早期暴露年龄了啊。
我有幸经历了中国电视剧市场。
真的是发展起来，就从80年代开始了嘛。
我经历了这个整个过程，因为我小时候特别爱看电视剧，特别爱看电视剧。
那种小时候那种电视台有8个频道，你知道吗？就8个按钮，8个小按钮，叭叭叭叭8个按钮，就看那种电电电视剧。70年代末的那些比我大一点的，应该还经历过那种拧的那种电视，就是那个调台是用来拧的，像个收音机，什么年轻人收音机也不知道是什么，反正就是一个像洗衣机的。
现在洗衣机也没有那种钮了，微波炉微波炉行了吧，微波炉那个拧的。
那个那个旋钮早期的电视电视机是那个旋钮的那种我也看过。
反正我是经历了这个完整的时代吧，我可以给大家回顾一下啊。
电视剧。
就中国电视剧的。
过去。
非常之辉煌。
中国电视剧曾经非常的辉煌。
非常的高峰。
你们无法想象当时有多。
牛逼。
有很多经典的片子，里程碑式的片子。
西游记。
这就不说了吧。
80年代温德版西游记横空出世，万人空巷。
非常牛逼。
这个这个卖给出口，世界上很多很多国家。
当然啊，同时期四大名著都拍了一下，那时候的老的三国水浒和那个那个红楼梦，红楼梦也非常成功啊。
非常成功，就是那个。
男女主角叫就贾宝玉和林黛玉分别是欧阳奋强和刘晓旭，是叫刘晓旭吧？
那那一个版本。
然后还有。
呃，渴望当时也是一个里程碑式的电视剧。
中国电视剧当时非常的牛逼。
而且。
还有那个年代就有偶像剧、言情剧。
演员你们可能知道啊，叫王志文。
王之文大叔年轻的时候是中国偶像言情偶像剧一哥。
一个。
一号小生。
真的。
真的，当然他年轻的时候其实也不帅啊，也就这样。就现在这个模样也不帅，但是他真的是在演偶像剧，他跟那个江山演的什么糊涂的爱呀，过把瘾呀。
那个也是中国电视剧可以载入史册的作品，为啥呢？
那应该是中国电视剧第一个。
舌吻的剧。
真的。
男女主角这俩头啊对在一块儿横着亲，绞着亲，然后摄像机360度转着拍，配着恨不得配着音乐撒着花瓣，你知道吗？
就那么亲呐。
你在现在的电视剧中还看到过吗？
早就没了。
审不过了。
年代就可以这样骑。
而且那个年代不光是中国内地的电视剧厉害。
整个电视剧市场蓬勃发展，引进片也是大家互相互相争争相斗艳，互相扶直，互相帮助的那种互相刺激的成长。
你想我们。
最早引进的。
港片是。
83年的社雕应该是83年社雕啊。
射雕英雄传。
天哪开启了整个武侠片的武侠电视剧的时代。
武侠电视剧的时代，射雕英雄传。
然后当时甚子都从新加坡引进。
电视剧武侠电视剧可能是因为武侠电视剧这个市场需求量太大了，然后内地暂时还没拍，因为内地当时比较严肃。
呃不太想搞武侠这块，自己不太搞武侠，因为觉得哇哇哇觉得有点我们内地人有点做不出来这种事儿，你知道吧？就有点不太想干这种事儿，然后呢就引进了一个新加坡的电视剧，我印象很深刻叫。
叫莲花争霸，好像是。
无怨无悔，我走过路，我是通过看这个电视剧才知道啊，新加坡人也说中文，懂吧？就是那个电视剧为啥？
印象很深啊，那个电视剧又跟咱们呃香港的这个武侠电视剧风格不一样。
他那个电视剧非反物理起飞。
香港的电视剧能打或者速度快，它至少基于物理原理。
就他不出格，就我速度很快，但我蹭了一下过来，我不出格。但是那个新加坡人他不管这一套啊。
他可以往后飞，腿一蹬它就往后飞，然后他可以手发冲一波往外放炮。
它可以瞬间移动什么的，它就可以开始走那那种路线了。
也是非常的经典。当然咱内地也拍了，也开始做多种尝试，拍了那个。
封神榜。
风筝榜那内版也是非常经典。
然后引镜片还有那个。
东京爱情故事。
东京爱情故事9192年左右的时候，当时也是爱情启蒙吧，算是。
还有引进的，还有什么啊？
那个港台地区的更多啊，像新白娘子传奇。
新白娘的传奇。
那也是当时让人觉得。
眼前一亮的电视剧啊，他唱啊。
说着说着就他就唱起来了，你知道吧？
而且他的男一号那个那个那个许许仙。
是叶彤演的，是女的。
但是在当时啊很多观众并不知道。
特别是在我们小县城，我在小县城长大资讯没那么发达。小县城对于叶童是男是女。
是有巨大的争议，而且没有定论的，没有人出来摆一句话说，他就是男的，或者就是女的，一直有争论到这种程度火呀。
还有引进美国片成长的烦恼。
在那个年代也引进国内。
还有ba watch。
就海滩游侠。
讲的是什么啊？讲的是美国海边一群救生员的故事。
就是穿着泳装。
每天在沙滩上奔跑救人。
能想象吗？在那个年代。
金发碧眼的女郎穿着泳装。
在沙滩上奔跑，还放慢动作给中国人看。
就是看的能很过瘾呢。
哎呀，所以说那个呃时代呀，中国电视剧的过去曾经无比的繁荣，无比的。
兴盛甚至到后期是一直到呃90年代末，一直都很棒，又出了什么呃那个那个啊，早期还有几部片子很啊编辑部的故事跟我爱我家。
那是大院儿。
流派仿美剧的开山制作这两部戏，他们都有点他们的形态都是模仿美国的情景剧。
包括叙事节奏和叙事结构。
因为那些大牌子弟很多人去过美国留学，或者是他们能睁开眼看世界，他们算是第一批人，然后把这种艺术形式引进了中国。所以其实像编辑部的故事，还有。
我爱我家。
你们年轻人肯定都没听说过这两部剧啊。
嗯，可以翻出来看一看，一点儿不落伍。在当时是非常前卫的，它的那些主题和内容非常前卫。
就因为它很美。
很美式的审美。
然后到后期啊到990年代后期，中国电视剧一直。
呃，时不时的出精品。
中国式离婚。
非常牛逼。
然后。
还有TVB系列呀哦，TVB那些港片当时也是非常好看，对吧？还有琼瑶系列。
琼瑶阿姨在中国电视剧史上，那绝对是泰山北斗，不得不。
呃，这个有他的。
巨大的一席之地。
他开创了一个时代。
第开创了一个流派。
非常厉害非常厉害啊，他写的他写的东西是很硬的。现在大家经常会嘲讽一些就也不叫嘲讽啊，就戏谑一些他的一些台词啊，这个在网上挺流行的。但其实当年我们看的时候是很过瘾的。
因为他是戏写的好。
它整个戏的结构。
和情节写的好。
绝对有他的一席之地。
然后后来还有一些什么精品电视剧，我印象当中的啊。
嗯，士兵突击士兵突击比较新了。
有些同学可能知道那部戏出来很多人啊，什么宝强啊、陈思成呀、张译呀、段奕宏呀，都是那部剧那部电视剧出来的。
那部电视剧我为啥印象特别深啊？因为那部电视剧当时。
没卖掉。
就是他被淘汰。
那部电视剧因为太怪了，你们现在可能感觉不出他有多怪，但当时觉得非常怪。
那部电视剧里面没有女性角色。
你能想象一部，我们说电视剧是广告的弟弟，他是在电视电视机里服务女性观众，陪着女性观众的。
对吧。
但是他的电视剧整个全是男性荷尔蒙。
而且还不算。
当兵的也没有服装上也没有变化。
场景呢也很单一。
然后呢，也没有女性角色，关没有女性角色就代表什么？没有情爱，没有爱情戏。
所以当时电视台都不买那个剧。
完成不了，他好看归好看。
但是他完成不了。
那个作用呀。
所以我印象非常深，那部电视剧后来就是先走的地方，结果在地方播的时候播火了。
才重回卫视。
等于还亏钱了。
等于还亏钱了，因为先走地方给的钱很少啊，所以这部戏我印象也很深。
还有什么戏啊？
刘老根儿。
刘老根其实也可以，我认为刘老根也应该载入中国电视剧的。
实测，如果出个纪念册的话，为啥？首先刘老根是一部非常优秀的电视剧。
何庆坤写的，然后赵本山高秀敏。
范围主演。
那部戏在当年也属于难得的良心电视剧。为啥？那时候电视剧普遍注水。
一拍拍的很长，为啥呢？因为很多电视剧是先卖再拍。
就你已经确定要买我电视剧了，那我就照死类注水拍个30集、四0集、50集、60集呗。
对吧。
很多这种情况，但那部电视剧他每一集的打点一看就是没有注过水，就是规规矩矩剧本怎么写的，怎么拍的。
然后呢，演员阵容也那就不用说了，当时都是巅峰期的铁三调。
最重要的我对那个电视剧印象最深是什么啊？
我当时看完那个电视剧，我最佩服的一点是什么？那个电视剧是非常少见的。
反派设置方式。
他的反派。
是乡长。
就刘老根要创业，他前进的路上，就他是经典叙事。刘老根创业。
经典叙事就是一个人物，一个事件，一个视角刘老根要创业，然后给他设置障碍。
没有钱呀，旁边的人不理解呀，这些都是小障碍，肯定要设的大障碍是什么？这个所有学编剧的人都懂大障碍，你要设要一个狠的呀。
他感示了什么当地的乡长。
然后冯乡长，然后冯乡长还有个搭档是公安局局长的小舅子。
等于这两个反派他设定的都非常的大胆。
非常的大的。
到现在绝对审不过。